now when the Supreme Court made the  decision about Roe v Wade we were told  that by the left including many of them  secular atheists doesn't matter what the  Supreme Court says women have the right  to abortion what do you mean right what  are you appealing to exactly when you  talk about this mystical right that  exists you're not appealing to God what  are you appealing to if you can only  appeal to man if you can only appeal to  the government then it's up to them what  the rights are and it doesn't make any  sense if the government says you have a  right to this it doesn't make any sense  to say no that's that's not true what do  you mean it's not true according to you  a right by definition is simply whatever  the government says this is a real  problem but I don't think anyone on the  left has even attempted very few people  on the left have even attempted to  confront or deal with or wrestle with  and it just makes everything they say  about human rights totally meaningless